لقد كنت شغوفًا بالمحيط
منذ أن كنت طفلاً وأتذكره بوضوح
في المرة الأولى التي ذهبنا فيها إلى القول كما لو كان
مجرد عيد الغطاس هذا ، أوه ، هذا
ما كان من المفترض أن أفعله
[موسيقى]
إحدى السمات الفريدة
للشخصية  - ثمانية هو أنني غادرت سان
فرانسيسكو في أواخر الصيف ، أبحرت على
طول الطريق إلى المحيط الجنوبي على
طول الطريق حول العالم وفعلت ذلك كله
في الصيف الجنوبي ، ثم أبحرت فوق
المحيط الأطلسي حتى نفد من المحيط
وأجعل  من الصعب ترك المنطقة القطبية الشمالية
وهناك - أنا هناك في الصيف لأن
هذه هي المرة الوحيدة التي يمكنك فيها الانتقال
عبر القطب الشمالي إنها المرة الوحيدة التي
يذوب فيها الجليد بما يكفي للسماح لك بالمرور
عندما تكون في أقصى
جنوب المحيط الجنوبي  في المنطقة الأكثر رياحًا
في العالم ، لا يوجد شيء
لإبطاء أنظمة العواصف في البحار
مثل المنازل المكونة من طابقين في معظم الأوقات ، حيث
يبلغ متوسط سرعة الرياح حوالي 2030 ميلاً في ال
اعة ، وهذا نوع من الإبحار في إيفرست لل
رادات لمسافات طو
لة.  لا تشعر عادة بالوحدة  هناك
الكثير لتفعله ، فليس الأمر كما لو كنت
جالسًا فقط تقرأ الحرب والسلام
كل يوم ، فهناك الكثير مما يجب فعله للحفاظ
على القارب للحفاظ على صحتك
للحفاظ على صحة القارب الذي كنت
أعيش في البحر دائمًا من
أجله  أشهر الآن لا ينام أكثر من
ساعة ونصف في كل مرة ، لذا لا
يبدو أن المرء لديه الكثير من الوقت للتفكير في
مدى الوحدة التي قد تكون عليها ولكن
بعد فترة ، نعم ، أنت مستعد للمس
قاعدة مرة أخرى فقط من لحظة
منظور بسيط ، أنا فقط أتطلع إلى
أن أكون في المنزل مع زوجتي بدأ هذا المشروع
في عام 2013 واشتريت القارب في عام
2016 ومن تلك النقطة فصاعدًا أبحر قليلاً إلى
حد كبير
لذا فهو يريد أن يتوجه إلى
البحر  مرة أخرى بسرعة كبيرة ولكن الشتاء
في المنزل بعد ثلاثة فصول صيفية ،
هذا جيد ، أنا بخير
[موسيقى]